did you know that right now there are
over 1 million
professional youtube creators and a
recent article from signalfire
stated that being a content creator is
one of the fastest
growing small businesses right now
and here at think media we are on a
mission to help 10 000
purpose-driven creators create a
full-time living
doing what they love and making an
impact in the world
through the power of youtube my name is
heather torres and you are watching the
think live show and today i am fired up
because we are going to be sharing with
you one of our think media community
members
matthew stratton who was able to quit
his medical professional job
create an income on youtube and go full
time with less
than 55 000 subscribers now matthew's
actually a part
of our online community here at think
and he
is a member of both video ranking
academy and inner circle and part of
being in our communities is you get
access to our think media team and so
tony from our think team sat down with
matthew during what we call
our vra show for our video ranking
academy
members and he interviewed matthew on
how he was able to go full time
what it took to get there what types of
videos he created to be able to grow his
views and grow as subscribers and
what full time on youtube actually looks
like because let me tell you it's not
all
jake paul and mr beast okay it's real
creators
just like you and me who are sharing
their message who are putting their
uh their expertise out there and helping
people along
the journey now i want to let you know
matthew does get real
and raw during this interview so i want
to prepare you
because what he invested in the things
he did
in in helping himself grow and being a
part of our think media community
changed his life and i thought it was so
impactful
this interview that i wanted to bring it
to you today on the think
live show so let's get into today's
featured content and make sure you stick
around until the end
because i'm going to be sharing with you
three tips of what has been
proven in going full-time on youtube and
i'm gonna be sharing with you a free
class
that you can take if you wanna learn the
three secrets to success of a
sustainable
youtube channel well let's get into the
featured content
and i'll jump back on right after tony
areola and matthew stratton
i want to start is your first video
what did your first video look like
matthew how did you get started with
youtube
you know now you're full time and all
these things happening for you
and we'll get to that in a second but i
want to look i want to take rewind the
clock back a little bit and what did it
look like for you when you
first started posting videos or recorded
your first video on youtube
all right so uh my very first video was
a very short video
of me unboxing a violin and the video
consisted of me
setting up a canon camera i had that i
used just to take photos like a
automatic camera put it on a tripod and
just
pointed it at me sitting on the floor
opening or unboxing a violin
and um i didn't talk the whole video and
what i did i just took one of my old
songs i had created
and just put it in the background as
background music and
that was my first video and surprisingly
enough
a couple weeks after releasing that
video like or even like within the first
week i like gained a subscriber and
people were commenting on it
and it was just it was really cool
that's amazing and what is it what was
it like
i guess that early journey when did you
have a light bulb moment where you
thought
i'm gonna try this youtube thing when
did that happen for you what was that
like
so like in my head
like when i first started right i was
like i'm gonna
i had already decided i was gonna like
do something like i wanted it to be
where i could live off of it for some
reason like i just got the idea in my
head
uh because i was watching this this
video this guy like
he was like acting out this thing where
he he was um
like his dad would take out his xbox
games and throw in the backyard and run
over him with a
llama and he's got like millions of
views and this guy's like making all
this money from this i'm like
if he can make money off of something so
silly like that i'm like i'm sure i
could do it and at that point in time i
thought it was all about just getting a
lot of views
and you know making money through
adsense um but you know
in the beginning i was really
inconsistent and i did videos like
kind of all over the place like uh the
first video was like
unboxing the violin and like the next
video was like
about solar panels and the next video
was like unboxing like
um like hard drives and then lighting
and then microphones it was just
kind of all over the place and vlogs and
um
you know it was really sporadic with it
and then um
you know if they're doing more and more
research um
you know like i figured out there was
other
things that you could do and um and like
being focused kind of helps out and um
i found i'm just going to go straight to
it i found trunk
think media and um i thought you know i
bought like lighting
that he recommended i actually have the
light over here it's just like a led
light
uh that sean cannell recommended and
you know i did like an unboxing video of
that and then like i just kept watching
a crap load of sean's video can i say
crap sorry
um and then um about lighting
microphones and everything like that
and then it took a couple years i'm not
even going to lie it took a couple
years of like working things out like
okay
if i can get more clear more specific
about what i'm doing
um and get more consistent um
i can actually put a few things together
and make money
like in other ways it's not all about
just youtube so i
shifted my mind from okay i got to get
millions of views
and millions of subscribers and then it
went from that to like okay i can add
this thing and then i can add this thing
to it
i watched like sean's master class like
six or seven times before i actually
even bought
the thing bought video breaking academy
and at the time i bought it
was september 11th uh 2018
and um it was like 400 at the time when
i bought it
and um but i bought it and then
honestly like sean a lot of times sean
says
um the transformation is in the
transaction
and then at that point in time like
there was just this whole
process going in like is this really
what i want to do like
and then like i was like i'm just going
for it because at the time like 400
is a significant amount of money to
spend on something to me especially when
you got free videos everywhere
but like something about taking that
step
in september 2018 like i had already
been posting videos for a couple years
but taking that step
purchasing uh video ranking academy i
mean like this is it i'm going to study
this
it was just like a mind shift like my
mind shifted my whole mindset
started to change at that point it was
like a whole transition period
i talked a lot i hope that helps that
was perfect
that was great and when did you start
realizing it was working like when
when was it for you what was that
experience like when you started going
wait i think i'm making a little wait i
think i'm making a little money here are
like
wait i'm getting some views what was
that moment for you that
kind of maybe sparked your fire go this
is actually working
so i did a lot of like
like i did a review video on my violin
and like
that first violin that i bought and then
a company contacted me was like hey do
you want to review another violin and
we'll give you a free violin and i
thought that was cool
and um you know so i but uh i thought
that was pretty cool but that wasn't
like
what really like had things click in my
head so i started doing videos i bought
something called the mpc
live i have literally like three of them
in the room
but it's this thing right here i don't
know if you can see that you probably
can't see that
uh it's the mpc so i bought this i had
was
looking for something i could make music
on that i could record my guitar into
and do drum beats because i used to be
in bands and um
so what i did is i found this because i
realized i could plug my guitar into it
and record guitar and then very easily
put drum tracks and bass lines to my
guitar
and then i just started doing videos on
that um
and then you know i watched a lot of
think media's
stuff in sean was talking about using
the
search space you know the like where you
use the search on youtube
and i would just put mpc live in the
search bar on youtube
and then all these things would start to
auto populate and it would say like
npc live setup and then i was like
okay i'm gonna do a setup video on npc
live and then it was like npc live
you know what and the list went on like
audio programs audio tracks
and then i started doing my own stuff
too but based off of that i was like i'm
just gonna do a playlist
off of this and um so i did an mpc live
setup video and then that video
kind of like people were searching npc
live setup so
that video shows up whenever you search
for it and people find that video
and in that video i say if you want to
watch the next video click or tap
well i don't think there was a tap at
the point but i was like the next video
is going to be right here
you can see the next video and that
video was like a video series
ended up being like 30 videos it was
like a ridiculous video series and i
called it the complete guide to the npc
lives or
it was like the beginners the complete
beginner's guide to the npc live
and i did like 30 videos just it's still
like my number one
like feud playlist today just because i
gave so many calls to action to go to
that playlist
and um that's when i started
like realizing okay well i'm getting
views from this
so that was like the first iteration of
recognizing that it was actually
working like the vra process was working
i don't know i mean no question what was
that at this point
no that was that was exactly i was
asking so what's
great about it is it's such a practical
like
i bet you most people maybe even
watching listening to this they probably
don't even know what the
npc is they're like that exists but
there's actually so many things probably
within your niche
that have a whole subculture around them
you don't even realize
that are there and i think there's
something powerful you shared earlier
what i loved was about the whole youtube
search bar
sometimes we like to overcome complicate
things and don't get me wrong i love all
the keyword search tools
and ones we recommend here as well i
mean all of them are great vidiq
all that stuff but there's something
about especially when you're just
starting
there's the power of execution right
matthew like
there's the power of i'm actually gonna
make videos and i'm not going to like
get too hung up
in that process is that what you found
was helpful earlier on it's just not
getting too hung up in the research
that's um yeah because even so
i had at the time keywords everywhere
was free and
i would see that it wasn't like i would
even like it would tell you how many
search
how much search volume was for it and i
even noticed like some of the search
volume was like pretty low
it wasn't like a lot of search volume
but i still knew there was an interest
so it's like
even if a few hundred people watch this
video
i'm gonna release a video i don't care
i'm not worried about like
because it kind of it was a shift it
wasn't like i'm trying to get a million
views it was like i'm just gonna keep
putting out content and just
keep going at it over and over so yeah
keyword like but anyway
you don't need keywords everywhere i
know it's paid now
if if i think i think if something shows
up in the search bar
at least one person has searched for it
so if you could find search terms that
way
there's some kind of interest in it and
you're not just making videos for no
reason
you know what i mean no totally that's
that's i totally agree with your
mentality on that i think it's important
especially early on if you're like
getting too hung up on oh like it
doesn't have enough big
big oh like i i know that was my
struggle when i started youtube was
oh i have to make sure my channel is for
everybody or like i have to like
reach everyone in the world and the
entire universe with my channel
which actually ended up being a
hindrance to what i was trying to do
with but when you try to build a youtube
channel a lot of times you try to reach
everybody you actually reach
nobody and i think there's power in
kind of getting a sense of like oh this
this autocompletes here
and i know about it so i'm just going to
make videos on it
and i think there's a powerful strategy
you had there too was making a series
making a series of videos i think that
there's when you end up making a series
there's a couple things that it does the
first thing is it gives you the chance
to
really have people latch on to you and
subscribe because they're like oh i can
watch your next video on it too
and you're building that relationship
with subscribers and stuff
but it's also just youtube loves it
youtube loves when you keep people on
the platform for a long time watching
multiple videos
youtube's like you're my best friend so
your full-time journey
you got you know you started off making
the violin video the unboxing
didn't have your face in there and so
now we see matthew stratton
all these subscribers you're full time
and just kind of recently full time
i want to know just from your
perspective what was that like to go
full time did you was it longer than you
thought
shorter than you thought what was that
experience like for you to go full time
of course it's going to
feel longer than i thought because i
want it right now
but actually i'm really so i've been on
youtube for
i don't know like four years i really
it's been like four years five
minutes over four years so
i've actually progressed at a rate
that's comfortable for me
like in the first video i didn't even
want to talk right but now i'm able to
do a live interview and talk
and you know conversate and i actually
have knowledge about this
so if i like you wouldn't want me on
this
vra show like in the first month like i
wouldn't be able to i wouldn't be able
to talk about any of this stuff so
it took the appropriate amount of time i
put it that way
and i'm really grateful for the actual
experience
in the entire process because
having that experience helps me
understand
you know where i can have this interview
with you guys thanks for watching and
i appreciate you um but um not only that
but like if i had a like say i came out
with a video
on the npc and it went viral
in the first month and i got a million
views on it
like i would i wouldn't know enough
about the npc to follow up that video
and then i wouldn't know enough about
the
uh you know yeah i mean that's pretty
much it to be honest
to be honest that's pretty much it so it
took an appropriate amount of time i
think
and basically when i took that shift
like from like i don't know what i'm
doing but i want it to work like i'm
just going to keep doing it too
okay you know i made i bought br vra and
you know it sounds kind of funny but you
guys already bought it so i'm not trying
to sell vra
what i'm trying to say is like there was
something in that process where it's
like
okay this isn't like just for fun
anymore it's like
this is a game of chess like sean says
let's play chess
it was like okay so if i'm gonna play
chess and i'm gonna compete in a
tournament
like i have to study it you know like
so that's what i started to do and um
and then there was also a shift i
remember sean you know saying this
through some of the inner circles i mean
inner circle as well
and sean says you know put out videos
like you're already full-time
put out the content like you're already
full-time like do it
like you're getting paid for do it like
you're already a professional
and so that's kind of the mindset i
started to take whereas like
i'm already full-time like there's not
even a question about it am i going to
do it
it's not am i going to do it it's i'm
doing it there's a shift
i even remember talking to sean at grow
a video live a couple years ago
and i told him i was like i'm going to
figure this out i'm going to go full
time he's like
you're already doing it because i was
already selling courses i was doing
uh affiliate marketing and like
just having like that little connection
just that
it just takes a few simple words it's
like oh
like i am already doing it like so
that's that's
if i can convey anything to you watching
right now it's like
put out content like you're already a
professional put out content like you're
already a full-time like you're already
running a business like you're already a
full-time youtube
content creator and then it's not like
am i going to go full time or is this
going to work it's
it's working it's it's absolutely
working there's no question about it
are people watching your video at all
well it's working
i hope that answers your question
absolutely
i mean so many great light bulbs there
moments i think that there's
power in knowing like it takes as long
as it needed to take
and i think there's wisdom too to know
that you know some people want instant
success
but instant success a lot of times we
wouldn't be ready for it
we like we see all the time where
instant success will actually destroy
people's lives
like people that blow up overnight that
you know
i think the studies are kind of
astounding on like even lottery winners
that they win the lottery all this money
on them
the stats are crazy of how many people
actually go back to being bankrupt again
millions of dollars were like how is
that possible
well they were actually given something
they didn't have the capacity
to hold really and i think there's
something powerful in that and a lot of
you that maybe are listening are
watching right now that
you're like i want to be full time now
and i get it because
and matthew probably be attesting to
this too is like we get it
we get it but there's something about
the process there's something that you
learn
that your capacity continues to grow as
you produce videos
as you continue to grind like i'm going
to keep trying to rocket this video
success i'm going to keep promoting on
my social i'm going to keep
you know doing the one-to-one combat and
like dm'ing people i'm going to be in
the comments of things
there's something about that that builds
your character to a place where you can
actually
hold the success without losing your
life or losing your soul over it really
and that's really what we try to do here
i think media and matthew's a great
example of that
is how do we have success long-term not
just instant success
and so share us a little bit matthew
about
i want to hear like what when did you go
full time what kind of job did you work
because i know a lot of people watching
right now
are probably like worked they work a job
right now so maybe give them some
encouragement but also tell your story a
little bit about how what happened with
you
all right so when i went full time
was my last day was the last day of
november last year
so my last day at my job the last time i
clocked out was at that time
and i had been working at that job for
six years
and i was i you know a healthcare
professional i worked
in a hospital full-time you know
the whole shebang benefits you know
retirement plan
everything all the benefits everything
and um
and it was it's a great it was actually
like honestly like
the amount of money i was getting paid
the benefits
you know putting in the time there like
is a really good job
and i'm really grateful for that and um
but
i just want to say i'm really grateful
for that yeah
sorry um
but to be able to be where i'm at right
now i'm like
even more grateful
because it's it's like on my terms like
i haven't
really words in like a couple weeks
and and i'm still making money it's just
phenomenal
sorry you're good man it is dude
it's emotional man like this is
life-changing stuff
i mean this is stuff that you're
completely changed your life man like
and i think it's just that's the realism
man like
that's that's the power of youtube bro
like you've been crushing man like
yes you've been crushing dude you've
been working
working so like i mean what did it look
like a typical week for you
what did it look like when you were in
that season typical week
so fortunately um first i want to say
you know i thank god
for my position i have a tremendous day
faith in god
but um i went um basically
i worked the weekend so the good thing
about working at a hospital is
that you could do 40 hours a week in
three days
so i would work saturday sunday and
monday
and then i would get four days off but
being thinking that it was full-time at
a hospital i had to drive
45 minutes to an hour there and back and
working 13 hours it was like
they were really long days like i would
only get a few hours of sleep
like on saturday night and then i would
have to go back in
and uh do it again and on top of it it's
a hosp
hospital like you know bless the
hospital workers because
you see some stuff
like i remember the last day you know
working at the hospital like
being with a trauma patient that was
shot twice in the head you know like
seeing that like in person like this far
away you know like
this far away from this person who got
shot twice in the head
in the emergency room and then and then
going from that and now i have to be
really sensitive with this
you know gown up and go into this room
with this patient that has covered like
positive code 19
and work with this critical patient and
doing this so
like it's just a really intense job so
going through that
tuesday was not like a very productive
day for me
because you know i had to recover i had
to rest even though honestly i still
would like
like i would come home sunday nights and
like record a video and like put it out
like i was like like once i was on the
mission i was on the mission i was like
i'm making this happen
like no matter what right and
so basically saturday sunday
and monday was were like pretty much
work but then i had like
um you know in tuesday was kind of weird
too
and but then i had wednesday thursday
and friday where i could be like okay i
want to make some vid
some youtube videos like i'm just going
to hustle i'm going to crunch down
i'm just going to freaking grind and
just go for it and i went for it
and honestly like it was years of like
not going out on the weekends
like not like hanging out with my
friends
and like doing different things like
before the lockdown like just
i'm gonna make this happen and um so i
would make videos on wednesday
thursday and friday and then i would put
those out and then there was a certain
point where
i was like okay you know i learned from
inner circle
like i was gonna i was like i joined
inner circle
with think media and they were it was
like when i joined it was like okay
it was like a live stream challenge and
then like the next month was like make a
course and i was like i'm making a
course now
so now now i'm like working on grinding
and making a course
and now and making youtube videos and
working
and then it's like okay it was busy
let's put it that way like
it was really busy i don't know that
yeah it does no it does answer questions
i think it's great to put it in
perspective that
you know some people it's just it is
work like it it's it is
like we never have like said and i think
you would be even
it would probably read me to say like we
never said like this youtube thing's
easy like it's not easy like
we're here to help and support and make
sure you can you can push through those
barriers but like anything in life it
was easy
everybody would do it like if it was if
it was just instant success
bottled up everybody would do it you
know and
there's something powerful at your story
and i think that some people are
watching right now and whatnot that are
probably identifying with so much is
that
like it's a journey man like people are
working full time they're trying to put
in
the extra effort on the weekends and an
extra spare time i mean
and and like you said very much thank
you to all the health workers thank you
as well matthew just for what you've
done
even in the mid leading up to this um
but i think it's just exciting to see
though what's on can be on the other
side of that hard work
and so i guess my question for you then
is this if you were starting from zero
right now like you're going okay
like everything you've experienced from
working
full-time and doing trying youtube
full-time and doing it both
like what would you encourage people
that are just starting out like how
how would you start and how would you
encourage them
all right so these questions this type
of question is
really honestly a challenge to answer
because everybody's
path is going to be unique to them right
so like i said earlier
like every step i took on my path was
like
almost perfect timing right to make me
who i am today
now that being said i can give you like
some kind of
generic advice right like
and it's kind of a double-edged sword
because you don't want to like take
you don't want to be too hard on
yourself but at the same time you have
to get the mindset to where
you're going to do something like you
have to get in that mindset right
and my advice would be
you know create your youtube channel get
good lighting
put your you know get a good avatar
upload it
get a nice banner saying when you're
going to make videos
and what your videos are going to be
about more for you
so you're taking yourself seriously like
okay i'm committed to
releasing one video a week about
i don't know washing cars or whatever
your
your niche is right
and then that way you're committed to it
right because
the first videos like not a lot of
people are going to see right
then i would say like don't be afraid
to like make mistakes or do videos that
are off brand
or like even if it sounds funny because
even if your videos are
like watching cars and then you do like
another video about
something completely different cooking
or something like in the beginning
you just need that data because what if
you're not your heart
isn't in the washing car so what if
there's not enough content to like
put out a video every week about
watching cars maybe a
a different niche would be better right
so in the beginning if you're not 100
sure what you want to do it's okay to
experiment for the first
few video 30 videos or whatever you know
and you didn't get data
now once you put out your 30 videos look
at the data like
what's doing well right
and then figure out okay well what's
resonating with my
audience like i did somebody was like
you need to break down the npc you're
really good at
talking about the npc so at that point
it was over now i'm
making videos about dmpc right so um
you know i'm not making videos about
solar panels anymore so
you know follow the data follow people's
comments
but um but yeah if i mean if you're just
starting out i just say go for it like
sean says
you gotta press record and i know i've
seen people comment like
you know once they get into vra and
everything like what happened to just
press
record well you got that's the first
step in anything
you have to start somewhere so the idea
is like you have to just start
like literally just start start before
you're ready like
it's like re it's just do it
commit yourself anyway that's my tip
that's my advice
that's amazing no i there's so much
value in that and i hope you guys that
are watching right now and
definitely in the comments below make
sure you're sharing your
aha moment or thing that maybe stuck out
to you from matthew
um i know there's a lot of people that
probably are saying you know hey myself
i'm holding myself back like a lot of
your story unlocked things for i think
matthew and i just appreciate it so much
and i think one of the last things i'd
love to ask you about
is you know what is it like now being a
full-time youtuber like what
what is it like like is it like people
want to know what that's like what is
that actually like
it's absolutely phenomenal um
it really is amazing i'm so grateful for
it and
it's it's like really cool and
it's really cool i mean it's phenomenal
i mean i don't know
what is it like it's like i can make my
own schedule i can literally make my own
schedule
um i know like the minimum amount of
work i need to do
uh to like keep kind of keep the minimum
going it's kind of predictable
at this point uh but it's been because i
don't know like for the past eight
months it's been very consistent and
it's still
like going up and um just having that
freedom to do that is amazing
instead of being like confined to like i
only have this many days a week
you know it's like it's my schedule
that's pretty amazing man well i just
want to say thank you so much for coming
on uh
the vra show today and if you guys want
to check out his channel it's actually
in the description of this
post um so make sure to be checking out
his channel and stuff but i just want to
say thank you so much man and just
thanks for sharing with our audience
tonight
thank you for having me on and um i hope
everybody goes full time i hope
everybody watches this get some value
out of it i appreciate you for watching
so so good that was an interview from
tony areola from the think team with
matthew
stratton who is a full-time youtuber now
and is a part of our video ranking
academy and my name is heather torres if
you're just tuning in
you are watching the think live show
and wasn't that interview just so
inspiring i love being able to
hear from creators just like matthew who
were able to
um to have the freedom i i saw some
comments in there that said wow this is
real and raw
and uh just thank you so much for the
encouraging words during that hey i want
to share with you
three uh tips for going full time and
really just kind of conclude what
matthew
talked about and before i do that i want
to let you know that we do have a free
one hour youtube class this show is
actually brought to you by
our thinkmasterclass.com so if you're
new to think media you're new to what we
do here
we are a team of creators who want to
help you uh achieve your youtube
dreams and you can do that first by
starting out on this web class
or watching all the free content that we
have here available for you
at think media and if you're curious
about how to join video ranking academy
you can do that by going to joinvra.com
and you'll actually get the best
current offer we have um for the exact
program that matthew
is a part of now three ways that you can
go full time and here's the thing
these are a recap of what matthew said
but i just want to really
highlight these three and number one was
consistently post
quality searchable content on youtube
and i love being able to hear matthew's
story on what type of content he started
out with and a lot of times when you're
just starting
you're in what we call the experiment
phase if you don't have previous
influence or not already an established
business model in some other
area of your life then when you come to
youtube you're probably in this
experimenting phase what kind of videos
do i like to make what topics do i like
to talk about
and i see so many creators held back by
this
point right here the idea of creating
consistent
quality searchable content now let's
break that down consistency
consistency is so important when it
comes to youtube because
you want to be able to show up for your
audience
you if you want people to show up for
you you should show up for them
we just did a video nolan mult from the
think team did a video on
how can how much you should be posting
on youtube how many videos per week
so i'll make sure that's linked down in
the description below for you so check
that video out if you want to know
what does consistency consistency
actually mean but the quality
researchable content
is the biggest piece of how matthew was
able to go full time
he found a niche he found that people
were searching for that and he started
creating
helpful teachable videos in that area
now can you still be entertaining of
course but it's not like he's doing
reaction videos to the grammys on his
channel
he's very specific he's very niche down
and he's making sure that he's creating
content
that is searchable on youtube that's the
exact strategy that we teach inside of
our program
video ranking academy tip number two if
you're here with me live
type out tip number one in the chat and
tip number two is
have patience for this process you know
going full time
opening up a business being able to
create a sustainable income
it does not happen overnight and yes you
do hear stories of people who
joined youtube and got millions of
subscribers
those are what we call unicorns
those are unicorns we want to teach you
how to have a sustainable youtube
channel
that is that is helping you be
successful in your own life whatever
that means to you
but it's also just understanding that
this process takes time
building influence of any capacity takes
time and i think
a piece of where creators uh start to
fail
or quit or they just don't get to that
point
is when they're not actually just having
patience for this process and you heard
it from matthew
he was grinding on those weekends he was
or on those weekdays and he was working
on the weekends and
he was missing opportunities to go uh do
things with friends and
someone said in the comments team no
sleep now let me tell you as a mom of
three who homeschools and runs this
business i am
team sleep all the way here's what it is
it's team priorities it's not about
missing sleep
it's about looking at the priorities
that you have in your life and
understanding
that if youtube is going to be the thing
you don't have a boss behind you telling
you you have to do it
so you got to step up and be the boss
that pushes you
to make it happen that's exactly what
matthew did but you have to have
patience for the process
youtube is not an overnight success
machine but youtube can be a sustainable
business
and will become and is one of the
fastest growing small businesses right
now
and then number three type number two in
the chat if you are watching live number
three
is you want to treat youtube like a
business
from the start treat youtube like a
business from
the start why because when you go
into a project thinking of it like a
business
your mind's expanded into the different
opportunities available
businesses make money
to stay in business right and so if you
go into youtube
just with the thought with the idea that
no i want this to be a business
and let me tell you it is a business if
you are working on it
like it can be an expensive hobby if
you're not actually making money but if
the goal is to make money on this
it's a business one if you live in the
us that's amazing for your taxes because
you're owning a business
two you could be a sole proprietor you
don't have to go out and do all the
things related to it
i digress but let me get back to this
treat it like a business meaning
if you were to go and open a coffee shop
right now
well maybe not right now because of the
way the world is but let's just say you
decided
pre all this that you wanted to open up
a coffee shop well
you'd probably figure out you know you'd
have some type of business plan it
doesn't necessarily have to be like
well-written but you'd have an idea
about like how much am i gonna sell
coffee for where am i gonna source the
beans
um how many employees am i gonna need
what do i want the aesthetic to look
like
how many customers do i need to come in
per day to make a profit
right you'll you'll think of it like a
business and
it surprises me how many people go into
starting a youtube channel
just lolly doll like just like nilly
willy
i don't even know where these analogies
are coming from but this is what comes
to mind right they just kind of
happen stancely making youtube videos
but if you go into this like a business
you start thinking
well what type of uh branding do i want
to have
what type of businesses do i want to
partner with what type of
income streams could i possibly have to
make this into a full-time thing you
know matthew
isn't just making money off of the
youtube adsense that he's getting he's
created multiple streams of income
through affiliate marketing through
creating his online courses and
communities
he's been able to generate income in
multiple ways
and that's why it's being able to stay
consistent because he's not just
in one stream or one type of an income
to go full time
he's thought about how do i make this
larger how do i expand what i'm able to
do and how do i
actually make a full-time living you
know the next step for matthew is
actually going to be to that hiring team
part
because in order to expand the mission
you need more people on the team to make
that possible
and so when you go into youtube thinking
of youtube like a business
you actually start to frame what you're
doing
in a different light so i just want to
encourage you that if you're just
starting out on youtube
if maybe you've gotten a few videos
posted if you've recorded videos
you have them sitting on your hard drive
you've edited it but it doesn't seem
perfect enough to post it i'm going to
encourage you right now
to get your videos posted how do you
grow on youtube you post videos on
youtube
and i can tell you there have been
several times
over the past couple years that matthew
wanted to quit he was like you know is
this all worth it
but you know what he probably is really
excited about that he didn't quit at
year two
that he he didn't quit after he posted a
video and it bombed
that he didn't quit after he was working
a full-time job and doing you to youtube
and not making any money
matthew right now is able to have the
financial freedom
the time freedom and really just the
load off of him
in the environment that he was in
because he pushed through
because he pressed record because he
didn't stop when he felt like quitting
so i would encourage you that if you are
on your road to full time that we're
here for you
the think media team is dedicated to
your success whether that means
you watch our free content on youtube we
have
university level content for free for
you to learn how to use your equipment
as well as grow on youtube if you want
to join us at a deeper level and be a
part of our online programs we walk you
step by step through the process of
creating videos
getting into the right niche figuring
out how you're going to make money on
this
and helping it be a sustainable business
that you can do without losing your soul
and then beyond that if you have not
taken our free class i want to encourage
you to
dive into our one hour class i believe
that lifelong leaders are lifelong
learners and so if you've not taken our
free youtube class
at the end of it we'll give you the
opportunity to jump into video ranking
academy
but i just want to tell you that people
like matthew
they're not rare they're here and you
are a part of our think community now by
watching this show
and so i want to just expand your mind
even more and say let's do this youtube
thing let's be a part of what's growing
online let's be content creators
who are making good content for a
purpose and impacting people for good
i want to thank you so much for watching
today's show and again
it was brought to you by our think
master class you can go to think master
class
right now to sign up for that class and
check out this quick ad and we'll catch
it in the next video
are you ready to start or grow your
youtube channel
do you feel stuck and need help
connecting the dots
join this free web class where you'll
learn the step-by-step playbook for
youtube success
we've helped thousands of purpose-driven
entrepreneurs
just like you grow their influence with
video
register today for this exclusive
training at thinkmasterclass.com